the ari spears sketch no no no no no
what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] was that man that [ __ ] was wild
b that was the
dumbest [ __ ] i ever seen it was the most
unfunny thing and then on top of unfunny
it was weird son stick to impressions
bruh well he was yeah it was yeah it was
a fascinating summer you know
i hope it's an impression i guess but it
was it was just
bad yeah that's the first time you guys
have gotten weirded out by something so
bad that you had to stop the video i
didn't know why y'all were watching it
mark was loving it bro yeah yeah
research okay we're gonna talk about it
on the show because he's rubbing his
face
already put it on the list
where else are you gonna rub baby oil
idiot okay
got baby
hello welcome to the creams
punctuated it still you're defending
pedophilia yeah obviously what do you
expect this guy to do
it's just so unfunny
that's the issue with it like it's like
awkward and unfortunate and long yeah it
keeps restarting yeah unbelievable
yeah i i don't know what is what is the
claim from the kid the kid now grew up
this was like 10 years ago and he's
saying that he was like groomed or
something i guess
oh the parent's parent is saying that
you traumatized my child oh really
i mean i don't know if your child knew
what the [ __ ] was going on but it's just
weird dude like don't touch the kid
don't make the kid do anything sexual
also the kids don't show
dude when he's rubbing the baby oil on
the kid
that's
even fully clothed it wouldn't be funny
but it'd be way less weird and you could
still make your point and when he's
jerking the gun
oh
yeah yeah it's terrifying right
everybody part of that sketch should get
a little heat you think yeah the
cameraman got to get heat i didn't even
write it yeah well there's no pushback
at all like the thing is you can make
jokes
you can make fun of pedophilia and [ __ ]
yeah i mean there's not a child there
that's getting touched yeah yeah yeah
like
yeah there's i don't know i i also don't
understand we're talking about this on
idiots like i don't even understand the
parents that bring their kids to be like
the the raped kid on svu
that's a weird thing like why would you
want like
your kid wants to be an actor that bad
yeah yeah yeah there's no way that they
want to be the raped person on svu yeah
it's usually the parent that wants the
kid to be an actor
ain't it [ __ ] up but you got to watch
nathan for you for that [ __ ] he like
does a bunch of sketches like i've heard
a lot about this guy nathan like you saw
you saw the claw sketch right what was
it clawing
wait play with because i don't know who
this person he's just dude nathan feels
like
he's like my favorite [ __ ] show but
he makes a sketch
felder feldman fielder fielder he didn't
sniper did anything bro his
motherfucker's unbelievable drake
indigenous kids
he makes a sketch where he has a claw
machine and he basically has his hands
handcuffed above his head and he's
there's a bunch of children in front of
him and he goes the claw is going to go
and it's going to unzip my pants and
unless i can get a key to unlock my
hands and push this button this sounds
fun and when it unzips my pants i'm
always into this it'll expose me to a
group of children then i will be and
then i have a police officer here who's
going to charge me as a registered sex
offender and i'm putting all of this on
the line tonight
and then that's you guys
bro this is unbelievable nothing about
that yeah you wanted me as insane you
listen to the right you were like let
him go
i just wanted y'all to know why he
defended the baby
okay i'm just saying
i just want y'all to know i just want
y'all to know that's one of his many
sketches but i don't get that's the same
as ari spears but the difference is that
while he's doing it he's making fun of
and he's self-aware of what he's doing
so he's having these parents and he's
explaining to parents okay so they're
gonna be a part of like this crazy stunt
you're okay with that and they're like
yeah yeah it's totally fine and he's
like well you know there's a chance i
could expose myself to your kid and it
could traumatize them and they're all
like
yeah but they're going to be in the show
right and he's like
yeah and like
they're like oh you're going to blur
their faces and he's like no we're not
going to and they're like nah that's
fine and he does this like he has like
child actors in different scenes and all
the parents are just like whoring them
out whatever you got to do put them in
the scene as long as they're on camera
put them in the front we don't let them
be the closest to the penis we don't
give a [ __ ] they all like just so it's
more exposing the parents he's not
actually going to go through so what
ends up happening where's the end yeah i
mean like jerks off in front of all the
kids or something like that yeah
yeah that's the whole thing yeah but
like the whole like i don't really think
maybe the parents knew that was going to
happen maybe
[ __ ] again naked get them on tv maybe
but yeah like these parents like
hollywood parents is like they're
probably the worst
but also i don't know i you can't blame
someone for being so desperate they're
like oh yeah i'm gonna put my kid we're
gonna all of a sudden i can blame you
i can blame you yeah also how desperate
are you gonna be you're gonna take him
to auditions and [ __ ] during the day yes
you don't have a job yeah get a job go
get a job these are working hours
[ __ ]
yeah i mean the [ __ ] are you doing it's
a weird thing to want your kid to be a
child actor yeah it's weird
it's especially knowing what happens to
like every child actor getting famous i
feel weird if i got famous having kids
that are kids of famous people you know
what i mean
that's like if you get famous having a
kid and will smith's kid jayden that's a
weird existence any famous person's kid
like even if if i got famous i'd be
worried about my kid wanting to make my
kid famous himself blows my mind yeah
usually
the parent isn't famous that wants a kid
to be famous and i don't think they're
thinking that far ahead in terms of
what's going to
happen i think they're thinking like hey
let me try to give my kid a head start i
understand what you're saying but in my
mind there's so many examples of child
actors
corey haim dead
like there's so many of these kind of
girls just wrote a book did you oh son
yeah
jeanette mccurdy my my girl who's a fan
of this show i'm glad my mom the book is
called i'm glad my mom died yeah and the
whole book is about how awful her mom
was her mom like would underfeed her
starve her legit like
she was sexually assaulted her like
uncheck her hymen like do all these
awful stuff while she was making all the
money for the family how do you check
her hymen though
so we don't do you come on bridge you
really need her yeah of an adult finger
here
[Laughter]
if she hit her with a little recall
laughs i mean historically people have
been checking hymans and cultures for
you know thousands and thousands of
years she's not saying she's not the
first person
you are
i'm defending him i'm defending him bro
[Music]
uh nathan for you no i'm not defending
i've been here i'm definitely trying to
get hyman too bro what if we take the
comedians that are pedophiles and move
them to a different comedy club and then
you move in with us and we just church
we cycle them around okay
you just have like the king comic that
just kind of moves them to different
ones why is that bad didn't t.i say that
though yeah what he has uh obgyn check
his daughter's hymen but at least he
goes to the professional he's just not
going down there themselves i don't know
enough about female anatomy you know
nothing son how many holes do girls have
down there
six not funny
they don't have six
six they got one in their [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of it that's true in their
[ __ ] get [ __ ] in
[Music]
[Laughter]
no different sleep that's two right they
got the p hole that's true yeah they got
the period hole that's true they got the
[ __ ] real good in their [ __ ] hole
and they got the [ __ ]
six
if you got big enough [ __ ] as a whole
what's a cave
what's a king to a guy
exactly that's a good point that's all
i'm trying to say all right guys we're
gonna take a break from this exclusive
patreon clip because uh if you're a
current smoker or an ex-smoker who still
struggles with cravings you gotta check
out fume okay fume is the natural
inherit inhaler designed for a better
safer and natural way to quit cigarettes
it's a no smoke no vape and no nicotine
replacement for the hand to mouth habit
of quitting smoking okay
fume handcrafts wooden inhalers and uses
cores infused with plant oils studied to
curb cravings they have flavors like
peppermint and conker with minty notes
to simulate menthol cigarettes and other
flavors like cozy chai and lemon berry
bliss for a sweeter experience and all
of their flavors are 100 natural no
harmful chemicals no artificial flavors
and absolutely no
nicotine i'm telling you look at this
[ __ ]
ah
i damn near picked up smoking when i was
at burning man i'm hitting this fume now
that i'm back and i'm good to go not a
cigarette in sight whether you're a
smoker or an ex-smoker who still
struggles with cravings fume is the
perfect tool for you so head to breathe
fume.com flagrant and use the promo code
flagrant to save 10
off your entire order that's 10 off your
entire order when you head to
h e b-r-e-a-t-h-e-f u m dot com slash
flagrant and use the code flagrant now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
clip you can watch the whole episode and
all of our patreon episodes at
patreon.com flagrant2 industry yeah
we're gonna quiz you on the female and
that's why i know all about girls you
could get all this [ __ ] wrong okay ready
here we go so good that's a penis
penis no she's one sneeze away from
having a dangling fall out of her bro
look at that thing see you can't have
any comments on females okay and i'll
tell you exactly what they are tell me
number four on this chart right here
number four is pointing to what cervix
not true no that's the that's the uterus
no number four is pointing to the uterus
the uterus i meant yeah okay so you're
over one let's keep going yeah yeah all
right number two is the cervix
endometrium is indicated by which number
ah come on bruh endometrium all that is
a little this
[Laughter]
come on which one's the endometer is it
three three three three three you guys
got a little endometriosis and you just
got the egg
let me get that out of there what is it
three you really don't know any of these
endometrium i think you probably only
know the ovaries but besides that i
don't think you know and the floatie too
but you don't know anything else yo son
why you took away the ones i knew
it was rude
you keep saying endometriosis that's the
blackest name that's not
endometrium
endometrium is what you're looking for
[Laughter]
what is no what is endometrium three six
three eight or six
i mean obviously there's the endometrium
and the ectometry
y'all don't really know that i know me
trying to
stop i know this my dick never been to
an endometriosis
what would i know about it bro why don't
i know about it my [ __ ] knowledge
stopped with my dick stop
right
which is at the [ __ ] philippines bro
once i hit the philippines i don't know
nothing else
come on you never squeeze the girls
philippines watch our bus you hit a
filipino tube
filipino dude bro
a lot i squeeze a filipino to watch her
bust
hell yeah ladies listening right now be
honest if you're looking at this image
that girl got a big old mound for a
[ __ ] you see that thing
all right
okay what's the endometriosis eight
yeah
there we go all right go number number
question three number two indicates the
oh that's the easy one oh i got that
there's the speed bag on the back
[Laughter]
you know the little speed bag
is represented
is it the vagina the uterus or the
cervix no that's the cervix bro okay
look at you okay i'm moving up here i
told you the parts of the [ __ ] i know
about you cause i'm in there all right
fallopian tube that's easy bottom
six is the end of it all right seven
like seven you know testies obviously no
that's the ovary yeah
yeah leah thomas got that
yeah good swimmers all right go keep
going next
what is that all right the uterus is
indicated by which number i already told
you bro
uno
nope actually no hold up
[Laughter]
pulled my dick out some endometriosis is
on the end of it and i'm like damn your
boy went dude
if i pull my dick out and his
endometrius
for real dude did i finish the test yeah
you gotta you pass yeah no he did not
congratulations you can you don't know
what's parts of the dick
i know all those
oh no
dick part quiz
that's not oh that's a quiz but we'll
pull it up okay here we go here we go
all right oh [ __ ] i didn't know there's
that many points
god damn it's like when you open up the
lego you're like oh this is a
complicated one
[ __ ] i mean this seems nice
[ __ ] my anus is on my dick
yeah real talk no not for real all right
anus go ahead uh one
nice there you go that's the easy one
all right next question actually but
this chart is missing one giant [ __ ]
testicle so he might not be able to get
this
[Laughter]
what is number six pointing to he's like
oh that's the bladder bro
that's the bladder i think bro look at
you okay i didn't even know that this
was multiple choice which number is
pointing to the seminal vesicles
what
oh the seminal vesicles yeah that's the
testicles
you thought that was a native american
tribe
[Laughter]
hold on come on you got this seminal
vesicles all right it narrows it down
you got either two
right here
you got three right here i think it's
you got six right here i think it's two
well it's 50 50 chance because we
already know what six is so i think it's
two
because that's where my semen's at
that's how oldest thing in three months
come on come on come on i wouldn't have
known that without multiple choice
though
i don't think my [ __ ] comes from that one
bro where does your [ __ ] come i think my
[ __ ] comes from the 11.
i think mike comes from the 11 that's no
that's not
your [ __ ] doesn't come from your balls
what
[Laughter]
what do you mean bro well it kind of it
kind of did
that it depends where has come what has
come to you calm is what comes out of
your dick right should i put on my
toothbrush when i'm
done having sex man wait
what is
this
what is
[Laughter]
when you're about to bust like pull out
real quick run to the bathroom and just
i'm just [ __ ] mustard yeah i call it
oral hygiene exactly four out of five
doctors
tax though
no this one's easy number two is
pointing towards you should get this
this one's important and it's also uh
the prostate yeah one girl stick your
finger up your ass that's what they
touch not mine
what do they touch when they go out
there they go the other way
down down the throat
they touch these in your mouth
they do they don't go they don't go the
other way all right
okay the prostate this one's pretty easy
oh no we just did that one yep okay i
got that one right again i'm really
impressed by your uh your mailing admin
let's do this as the last one okay it
wasn't number three pointing to
the seminal vessel yeah we just did that
yeah that's how easy the male anatomy is
they just reuse no they ran it back as a
dumb ass got it wrong
he's like oh we gotta get this stupid oh
look dumb ass got it wrong stupid
[ __ ] idiot
the rectum is number four bro i thought
that was the anus oh
come on bro you never had a tongue in
your wreck
okay no guys
i'm surprised how much about [ __ ] you
know yeah he's a nurse i was a nurse
doug i forgot about that he basically
had a vagina for three years so
that was fat i did
and you didn't know much
i didn't know much i need more than you
but i know much
and you knew surprisingly a lot
is it because you had so many girls in
your family
no like that would come like that like
you would overhear like them scissoring
or whatever
[Music]
no no no i'm saying like obviously you
have to learn about that [ __ ] because
you're around them yeah that's yeah is
that what you learned about it no my
wife is a midwife oh [ __ ] she knows
everything about my hair i'm in class
where she does class at home and i wake
up at 8 in the morning with them talking
about this [ __ ] oh my god i want to get
an honorary degree
an honorary degree yeah like [ __ ] yeah
that should be fire yeah you know they
do have like golden retrievers like some
girls seeing eye dog we got like a
little like sachet around them when they
graduate i want that that is fired up
i've been doing hours in this class i
like know all the people's names i can
answer questions wait for real yes she
does the class at home i've been there
and is it is it gynecology basically
yeah no it's midwives
what midwifery that's better yeah
that sounds like some [ __ ] at hogwarts
right that [ __ ] sounds fire but
gynecology is crazy bro yeah
do you know what obstetrics is yeah
what's that
when you when you're trying to not have
sex okay
absolutely yeah i think abstinence
obstetrics that's absolutely well we
call that obstacles